à mon sens à partir du moment où on est
sur le terrain des pratiques anti trust
il est évident que la commission
européenne va pousser je pense à son
paroxysme blanquette et puis vous savez
que derrière tout ça c'est une histoire
de gros sous
facebook notamment mais amazon google et
les autres s'affranchissent des droits à
payer en conséquence
c'est également l'arroseur arrosé dans
un premier temps c'est à dire que les
communautés vont pousser je pense au
maximum et à leur paroxysme les enquêtes
pour essayer de faire tomber les grandes
pour que ceci bien évidemment un règle
les impôts pour lesquels est justement
ils s'affranchissent ans en partant dans
d'autres pays qui ne sont pas assujettis
et zoomer